bon alors si je comprends bien un homme
avec un masque qabous qui a donné
l'assaut avec une armée de robots
volants miniatures des micros book 18 b
max oui monsieur l'agent micro rambo oui
il est contrôlé par télépathie avec un
euro cerveau transmetteur soir je ne
suis pas rapide
non sans blague
alors monsieur qabous qui a usé d'un
moyen paranormal pour vous attaquer toi
et ce ballon ambulant
vous devez croire que je délire petit si
j'appelais plutôt tes parents pour
qu'ils viennent chercher quoi les
grilles ton nom et un numéro sur cette
feuille de papier pour conter aux il
faut qu'on capture ce type mais pour ça
tu auras besoin d'une petite mise à jour
cinglé avec un masque iliad essayé de me
tuer c'est pas génial ça fiche la
trouille évidemment mais c'est tout
qu'est-ce qu'il prend batterie de change
est rentré mon ange nous avons sauté
d'une fenêtre qui hélas nous avons jeté
d'une fenêtre
bb poilus bébé poilus